[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour un
nouveau 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire où nous discutons des
sujets qui font l'actualité
la restauration collective sert près de
3 milliards de repas chaque année un
million d'entre eux partiraient à la
poubelle pour lutter contre ce
gaspillage les collectivités multiplie
les mesures notamment dans les yvelines
des initiatives pour les déchets
alimentaires mais aussi pour tout ce qui
touche emballages et serviettes on en
parle avec nos invités laurent burson
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes maire adjoint
à maurepas vous êtes déléguée à la vie
scolaire richard mézières bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes maire-adjoint à
guyancourt délégué à l'éducation et en
visio alexia de blangy bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes directrice générale de ces
midi la seule structure créée par les
yvelines et sodexo pour gérer la
restauration et le nettoyage des
collèges du département et virginie
pujol bonsoir mon poids vous êtes
responsable qualité de ses non dits
alors depuis le 11 février 2020
l'objectif national en france est de
réduire le gaspillage alimentaire d'ici
2025 à 2 50% par rapport à son niveau de
2015 notamment dans la restauration
collective c'est 120 grammes par plateau
et par jour qui sont jetés laurent
burson à mort par au sensibilise depuis
2010 9 de manière plutôt ludique vous
avez arthur qui est un robot pensé par
les agents de la ville oui tout à fait
on a mis en place en dehors en 2018 un
service petites faims grande faim qui
permet donc aux enfants de suivre leur
appétit de choisir ou pas l'entrée de
choisir une grande assiette pour le plat
principal ou une demi portion est pareil
de choisir ou pas le dessert et en fin
de repas à partir du moment où ils
doivent heures donc débarrassé leur
assiette il il pèse en fait les déchets
qui grèce qui restent dans leur assiette
avec un robot qui en fait qu'il ya un an
et qui devient rouge si le poids est
trop élevé
les enfants ont tout de suite pris
conscience c'est ce qu' il n'y a pas eu
cette petite angoisse que ça devienne un
jeu aussi qui s'allument kantien ceci en
fait c'est ça s'est mis en place en lien
aussi avec l'équipe enseignante de
l'école des coudrais et notamment sa
directrice mme guillon qui a aussi fait
une sensibilisation dans les classes
pour ce donc pour ce gaspillage et est
depuis d'ailleurs ça a été mis en place
dans trois autres écoles même c'est un
peu freiné la avec la dir les mesures
sanitaires mais l'idée étant de
développer sur l'ensemble de la ville
évidemment virginie pujol c'est midi ce
sont pas moins de 46 mille élèves qui
déjeunent dans les cantines quelles sont
les mesures mises en place
oui donc un succès midi nous avons
effectivement équiper l'ensemble de nos
établissements en bande de cris pour
justement pas que les convives puissent
trier les déchets ou au quotidien nous
avons un programme en interne de lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
qui s'articule autour de pluzz et de bio
déchets générés par zones qui sont
ensuite analysées dans cet objectif
justement de réduction donc on
sensibilise nos collaborateurs et nos
convives régulièrement à ces aspects
justement de réduction du gaspillage
alimentaire alors à guillon a lésé
madame de danger vous complétez
effectivement leur doux et en amont du
gaspillage aux formes nos agents à
préparer des repas effectivement les
plus attractifs les meilleurs pour les
enfants voilà on travaille sur les menus
et sur les produits la présentation des
produits est ce qu on sait qu un enfant
il mange aussi avec les yeux
sur la variété des menus et après
effectivement les enfants d'un trident
déchets à la fin des repas et nous on
analyse pourquoi ce déchet voilà est-ce
que ce déchet
a été engendrée parce que l'enfant mais
il ya des trous dans son assiette donc
on a mis en place dans certains collèges
effectivement petites faims grande est
ce que le repas ne convenait pas au goût
des enfants et puis ça permet de
retravailler aussi nos fiches techniques
et nous fiche recette pour apporter de
la qualité attendue pour les combinés
alors à guyancourt aussi depuis cette
rentrée il n'y a pu cinq copains aux
composantes sur les plateaux repas vous
aussi c'est pas nécessairement la petite
faim grande faim il ya plutôt quatre
composantes est ce qu'on peut expliquer
et parle effectivement à l'occasion du
renouvellement marché de restauration
qui a vu au premier au premier jeu et on
a mis en place quatre composantes nous
depuis 1er juillet qui sont proposées
aux enfants leurs quatre composantes
c'est cinq composantes qui sont
distribués en quatre on est bien sur
l'équilibré alimentaire qui est
respectée pour les enfants l'objectif
avec ses quatre composantes déjà c'est
pour être un peu plus proche de ce qu'on
peut trouver dans une famille dans le
cercle film familial c'est rare
maintenant de combes d'avoir cinq
composantes dans un repas et les cinq
composantes nous avions précédemment
sont prédisposés dans les quatre autres
plats
l'objectif c'est d'éviter un peu le
phénomène de pico agents s'étaient rendu
compte qu'on avait des enfants qui
piquent aurait un peu dans chaque plat
et qui ne finissait pas leur assiette
donc l'objectif de passer ses quatre
composantes ben c'était un peu recentrer
les enfants sur ce qu'ils ont dans
l'assiette infections on a fait aussi
les petites faims les grandes faims où
nous nous permettre vie des écoles sont
très très encouragés à faire des belles
plantations comme ce qui est expliqué
par ces midi parce que voilà des fruits
qui sont bien des coupes et des fruits
qui sont bien préparés ça donne envie de
les manger où on a mis en place des
centrifugeuses que des fois des free
c'est un peu compliqué pour les enfants
mangent et donc le fait d'avoir des
centrifugeuses dans nos restaurants
pédagogique pas ça permet à l'enfant
avec des oeuvres directement pressé sa
pomme et puis la manger alors que sinon
peut-être qu'il aurait eu la flemme pour
la préparer la découpe et donc il ya pas
de petites initiatives comme ça qu'on
est capable de mettre en place au delà
notre nouveau marque de restauration
pour encourager à faire moins de
gaspillage gaspillage et puis
sensibilisant ce qu'il ya dans leur
assiette on parlait de petites faims
grande faim je m'adresse surtout à vous
messieurs puisque vous êtes sur des
primaires et de maternelles donc en
train d' enfant de trois ans et un jeune
de dix ans ils ont dix ans quand tu y
rentres cm2 j'imagine qu'ils n'ont pas
aussi les mêmes portion ça a été adapté
monsieur bur sont
des normes haccp
qui donc qui définissent le grammage de
chaque aliment à chaque repas enfin sur
une journée et donc par rapport à ça
donc le grammage évidemment pour les
maternelles n'est pas né n'est pas
identique à celui des élémentaires
on a des recommandations qu'on doit
assurer conçu alors bien sûr des fois il
ya des inquiétudes des parents mais
niant tout ce que les ics avaliser les
équilibres alimentaires sont bien sûr
respecter les grammages on doit il faire
attention au delà des commissions
restauration avec eux des parents
d'élèves avec l'associé de restauration
avec des décisions sur lesquelles on
parcourt chaque minute et on vérifie cet
équilibre est qu'ils aient bien des
protéines des vitamines des féculents
cannes une attention vraiment très très
régulière l'aspect de ces
recommandations les thèmes de bourges
les plus jeunes
dans les collèges il y a aussi des chefs
qui réfléchissent à des recettes c'est
souvent remis on
on imagine comment faire manger
peut-être de nouveaux produits dans de
nouvelles circonstances
oui oui tout à fait voilà nous
travaillons vraiment au quotidien pour
justement suivre de près l'appréciation
des repas amélioré la qualité des menus
on a un club un club des chefs qui
effectivement réglisse de recettes
propose de nouvelles recettes toujours
justement dans le but de satisfaire les
jeunes collégiens
chaque jour une variété de repas
permettre à chaque enfant de trouver
osiatis faction c'est à dire qu'il va
voir trois ans crée il avoir un client
d'un prestement il ya un pas belge et à
rien
il ya trois produits laitiers il ya
trois desserts et voilà c'est deux
heures de donner envie à l'enfant
déjeuner pour limiter le gaspillage
alimentaire
et le vin on a beaucoup travaillé sur le
pain aussi le pain qu'un élément
essentiel d'un pad un français parce que
les gros consommateurs de pain
s'aperçoit que de couper le pain avec
des petits morceaux ça permet de limiter
le gaspillage du pain parce que quand
vous donnez un gros morceau de pain un
enfant pas beaucoup elle ne finisse pas
donc on préfère qu'ils en prennent pour
ce canton que voile beaucoup aidé
plusieurs petits morceaux plutôt que
donner des gros morceaux à chacun
josé vue jacquier ces messieurs le pain
c'est aussi une notion dans les cantines
sur maurepas ya ça fait trois ans
maintenant content précédemment notre
prestataire de restauration se
fournissait en pain dans une entreprise
qui fait qu'il faisait donc en grosse
quantité et depuis trois ans maintenant
on se fournit sur une boule chez une
boulangerie de maurepas l avantage c'est
que sur la restauration scolaire enfin
je pense que c'est pareil aussi à
guyancourt on est sûr de la liaison
froide et donc le pain était achetée la
veille donc vous imaginez un pain acheté
la veille là on est sur du pain qui est
livrée le matin dans les écoles donc sur
du pain frais évidemment en termes de
goût de goût et de qualité c'est pas du
tout la même chose pour les enfants et
notre prestataire pour l'ensemble
justement des denrées comme disait mais
mesdames tout à l'heure on travaille
aussi sur la qualité avec le prestataire
sur le fait d'acheter des pas des façons
c'est aussi de plus en plus demandés
mais on n'a pas attendu la loi légalise
pour ça mais de faire en sorte d'avoir
des monnaies des produits qui sont de
qualité et bien présenté également sa un
pain une baguette qui ne croustilles pas
ce n'est pas un pas effectivement sur la
difficulté je reviendrai ce qui
expliquait sur
voir un boulanger local nous n'a reçu
aussi avoir un boulanger local avec
d'autres prestataires et c'est pas
facile de trouver un boulanger qui est
ouvert le 5 jours sur 7 donc les cinq
jours de la semaine toute l'année y
compris pendant les vacances les
périodes scolaires parce qu'on a la
restauration qui fonctionne et des
scolaires dans le périscolaire donc on a
réussi à faire ça et c'est vrai que la
qualité du pain et ça semble sentir le
sentier très rapidement et également sur
les veinards qui sont proposés à goûter
et un petit exemple sur le gâchis les
déchets ce qu'on a pu faire c'est ne
serait-ce que travailler sur la position
du pain dans le neuf le choix du prince
n'a mis au départ le choix du parrain
était au moment où vous prenez le patois
découvert et là on s'est rendu compte
que les enfants pour les du par et puis
le temps qu'ils choisissent leurs plats
dans l'accueil ne mangeait pas qu'il
avait choisi les dons qu'ils arrivent à
table n'est presque plus fort et a gâché
leur donc on a mis le pas en fin de
service donc là ça change tout parce que
du coup il ne se gagne pas de pain
attendant et on a vu une réelle baisse
et a un réel impact sur la production de
voile sur les restes qui était produit
alors ce qu'on dit souvent c'est que le
meilleur déchet c'est celui qu'on de
l'eau qu'on ne produit pas on a beaucoup
parlé de l'alimentaire mais les gestes
peuvent se faire aussi sur d'autres
notions je vous propose qu'on parte à
magny les hameaux la commune a décidé de
dire au revoir aux serviettes en papier
puisque depuis la rentrée les élèves et
utilise pardon des serviettes en tissu
regardez
c'est devenu le rituel des écoliers même
quoi depuis le 20 septembre avant de
rentrer dans la cantine ils récupèrent
leurs serviettes en tissu encore
quelques oublis mais la démarche est
déjà comprises j'ai divatte et c'était
bien pour l'écologie de la planète
engagerait mois de de papier parce que
le papier c'est avec les arbres et
j'aime la nature c'est bien comme ça on
utilise monde serviette ça fait il ya
moins de pollution tous les lundis on
met la la serviette dans le casier et
tous les vendredis on a récupéré en
place un changement d'habitudes qui
permet d'économiser 100 mille serviettes
en papier par an une volonté de la
mairie une serviette en papier mais
trois mois à se décomposer
ça fait partie d'une démarche plus
globale par rapport à la réduction des
déchets et notamment au niveau de la
restauration scolaire on a d'abord
commencé à réduire notre usage du
plastique de manière générale donc par
rapport à ça on travaille avec des
barquettes compostables par exemple
depuis maintenant deux trois ans la
municipalité a aussi distribué des
groupes pour limiter l usage des
bouteilles en plastique lors des
pique-niqué au quotidien la ville
introduit aussi des produits issus du
commerce local dans les menus des écoles
virginie pujol dans les cantines des
collèges et viennois il ya aussi les
chefs est-ce qu'ils ont moins de
barquette est ce qu'il ya des choses qui
ont été mises en place aussi pour
limiter les déchets qu'on en alimentaire
leur haut niveau de la restauration des
vies on a quand même une grosse partie
du coût des collèges qui compte en
production sur place ou du coup la
question ne se pose pas les produits
sont cuisinés le jour j pour une
consommation à jour j après pour les
quelques sites que nous avons en livres
et
en majorité oui on est en livraison bac
gastronomes 1 en inox pour justement
éviter l'utilisation
barquettes barquette plastique
monsieur les ers accueillant pour les
goûters ne sont plus aussi en parts
individuelles ce qui souvent rend fou
dans les centres commerciaux avait
beaucoup de goûter précédemment qui
était dans ce déballage individuel donc
là aujourd'hui par ample et les quatre
cas ce fonds des quatre quarts des
grands quatre carrés ce sont des
animateurs qui découpent en portions
individuelles le 4/4 aux gays le fromage
blanc c'est dans des gros
conditionnements c'est plus dans des
dons des petits emballages individuels
sas a permis effectivement 2
de baisser fortement notre production de
déchets par les baguettes et les
barquettes compostables on met des
moyens humains en place voilà c'est ça
oblige à mettre des animateurs parce que
l'animateur pendant qu'il est en train
de découper son préparer le goûter pour
les enfants mais il est plus dans ses
fonctions d'animation mais voilà si on
veut réduire tous ces déchets produits
ça fait partie des efforts à faire et
des choses qui nécessaire de mettre en
place et monsieur tu reçois ce que des
fois ci les initiatives viennent des
élèves alors là pour juste pour rebondir
sur les goûters en fait on a fait le
même choix mais déjà pour une raison
simple c'est en terme de qualité c'est
vrai que les les goûters sous cellophane
c'est aussi quelque chose que l'enfant
donne ça lui donne l'impression d'avoir
quelque chose de très petit en fait par
rapport à une tranche de quatre cas ou
même du pain on pense à nos goûters
d'enfants du pain et un carré de
chocolat et du beurre voilà c'est
quelque chose que les enfants apprécient
beaucoup et donc on est aussi mise en
place au niveau d'aidé des enfants
cdc ponctuelles face et suivant les
écoles en fait les écoles comme je
disais l'école de coudray qui est qui
est bien avancé sur sur cette
sensibilisation ben oui il ya un gros
travail de fait avec les élèves etc mais
également les parents puisque justement
là prochainement sur cette école il va y
avoir alors on est après la presse donc
ce qui reste de déchets il en reste
malgré tout mais la mise en place d'un
poulailler donc sur l'école qui va qui
va prochainement arriver et c'est un
petit peu long pareil
darcos a entamé mais aussi de
l'organisation puisque
sur le temps scolaire ça pose pas de
souci d'avoir un poulailler mais vous
vous imaginez bien qu'il ya plein de
moments dans l'année vous il n'ya pas
d'école et donc il fallait aussi ben on
va dire
conventionnés donc avec une association
de parents d'élèves etc pour mettre en
place et là ça devrait arriver très
prochainement il est temps que quelques
parties des déchets donc haye
enfin se servent donc à la nourriture
des poules et les heures amassés par
l'epa
s'y promener sur les initiatives des
enfants et on arrive à renouer un
conseil municipal des enfants qui
concerne des enfants un peu plus âgés de
celle de cm1 jusqu'à 25 m et l'année
dernière ils ont produit un guide du
goûter et ce guide du goûter ils ont
produit en observant le nombre
d'emballages qu'on pouvait voir un
emballage individuel pour pouvoir les
poubelles précédent et celui du goûter
donc construit autour d'éléments qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de trouver des
recettes de goûter qui peut la courgette
pour faire des flancs des pneus chocolat
est donc assez bien une initiative des
enfants pour utiliser des choses qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude d'utiliser pour faire
des goûters et pour surtout moins
consommer en sachet de l'est lyonnais
donc montrer leurs camarades pour faire
des choses rapidement la maison qu'ils
sont bons des bonnes choses et qu'on
peut venir manger après mon côté l'école
oui parce que plus tard on dit de lutter
contre le gaspillage mais le zéro déchet
c'est impossible au département c'est un
système de méthanisation près de
carrières sous poissy est ce qu'on peut
présenter un petit peu son principe
alors qu'en
virginie vous expliquer que les enfants
trie les déchets est la fin du service
1-0 leurs déchets plus tôt donc il ya un
bac es déchets qui sont le pot de yaourt
un servette en papier il ya des déchets
qu'on va pouvoir mutualiser les
biodéchets il ya une entreprise une
start up qui s'appelle trion qui a
installé qui s'est installée à carrières
sous poissy qui ramassent c'est bio
déchets pour l'aider tamisage après
voilà donc c'est vraiment une économie
circulaire la plupart des produits dans
les assiettes des idées noires viennent
des yvelines et puis après ça va trion
ramasse les déchets pour le maîtriser
pour en faire bénéficier les entreprises
ou des particuliers à côté de carrières
sous poissy alors on l'a vite faits
évoqués tout à l'heure notamment autour
du pain
souvent si on ya la pollution quand on
amène les produits les collectivités ont
donc régulièrement recours à
l'agriculture responsable des produits
bio et ou locaux dès la rentrée 2010 9
au département la part des produits
était de 68% et vous souhaitez atteindre
93 % en 2025 c'est quelque chose
d'accessible
oui c'est possible on s'efforce de
répondre à cet engagement alors après
notre engagement et l'engagement que
veut le conseil départemental des villes
c'est promouvoir le territoire
événements et nous avons effectivement
nous nous efforçons chaque jour à
trouver des producteurs et bin-houin
donc nous travaillons en toute la salle
à deux des événements vient de monter
son les lentilles à vienne
218 haussier on a vraiment des produits
la majorité des produits crudités et
cusiter viennent ils sont produits et
dans les yvelines
voilà
sur maurepas aiguille en course est
aussi possible on sait que saint quentin
en yvelines met en place des vergers il
ya beaucoup de projets sur ces notions
manille à plusieurs fermes aussi sk
maurepas vous avez cette notion là alors
donc nous ça passe pas ça passe par un
prestataire s'est dit déçu là ces mots
mais là ces mots travaille beaucoup
effectivement avec des producteurs
locaux alors on en est pas 78%
on s'en approche peu à peu mais l'idée
effectivement travaillé avec donc on
travaille avec des fermes la ferme du
tremblay pour des yaourts cet art etc
mais donc là c'est le prestataire a
lui-même qui met en place toute façon il
a aussi une obligation par rapport à ça
et c'est aussi notre souhait de toute
façon idem j'imagine
bien d'autres marchés conditions du
marché au 1er juillet donc dans ce
marché on a inscrit des critères assez
sévère sur la foi du circuit court dont
en circuit court donc ses limites et mon
intermédiaire entre la cuisine et puis
la production et donc là on est à 70 %
donc circuits courts avec 50 personnes
locales et puis on est à 30 % aux
produits bio avec un objectif d'arriver
à 50 pour ça on l'a fallu marcher dans
quatre ans mais effectivement ce sont
des choix politiques c'est par nous
cahier des charges qu'on écrit qu'on
impose à nos prestataires de répondre et
puis d'aller on a une loi de légalisme
qui encadrent un peu ça marche qui
encadrent un peu la restauration dans
les collectivités mais le flou politique
est d'aller plus loin que c'est légal
hymne pour la langue anglais encourager
la locale les circuits courts la
découverte la diversification des
protéines pour aller voir autre chose
que des protéines typiquement animal par
des protéines végétales propose à tous
les jours avec ses semblables la
spécificité c'est qu'on a misé depuis le
1er juillet un double choix sur le plat
principal avec un bas à plat à base de
protéines animales ou un plat à base de
protéines végétales tous les jours et
c'est l'enfant qui choisit en fonction
de ses habitudes son souhait le plat
qu'il souhaite qu'ils souhaitent avant
pour sa restauration alors on a vu
pendant 20 minutes à peu près tout ce
qui était déjà mis en place mais est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez déjà vu une
baisse des déchets dans vos communes et
dans vos dans les collèges mesdames de
venger et pujol
vous mais on est faite de par l'analyse
qu'on porte sur notre programme d'anti
gaspillage voilà on analyse chaque mois
nos données on peut remarquer une
diminution
conséquence effectivement sur les
établissements notamment avec tout le
travail qui a été fait sur le pain tous
sur le pont le positionnement du pain au
niveau de la ligne de self est également
comme on vous en parlait tout à l'heure
au niveau de tous les axes
d'amélioration sur lesquels on travaille
au quotidien les menus l'environnement
de la salle de restaurant la qualité de
prestation la valorisation de la
prestation donc voilà vraiment en
travaillant au quotidien sur surtout
chez vague d'améliorations on note déjà
une amélioration
et effectivement on tend au corps vers
perdu positif c'est dur sans vous aussi
à maurepas
et visible qu'il ya une baisse alors je
parle d'une baisse on va dire des
déchets dans l'assiette la problématique
qu'il nous reste encore à traiter c'est
une baisse on va dire de la préparation
de ce qui est préparé parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement on a des
déréglementations terme de grammages et
c'est ce qui fait que quand on commande
un repas de la forcément il a ce
grammage la même si l'enfant va en
prendre qu une partie puisque petites
faims grande faim malgré tout le produit
il a été confectionné donc il faut qu'on
travaille qu'on poursuivre ce travail
sur justement ce qui est apportée en pro
de par leur parle notre prestataire pour
diminuer les quantités parce que malgré
tout ça reste jeter quand même vous
voyez c'est juste que 5000 enfants qui
s'est passé c'est positif quand même
parce que l'enfant n'a pas cette
sensation de jeter et donc du coup et on
va dire éduquer à ne pas gaspiller mais
malgré tout les denrées produites elles
sont malgré tout jeter quoi aujourd'hui
je ne l'aurais pas non plus de chiffres
a beau donner parce que déjà avec le
marché qui viennent d'arriver c'est un
peu difficile de voir l'impact tout de
suite par contre on a bien sûr prévu
cette opération de mesure avec la
sensibilisation on va faire avec les
enfants on aura des repas quand il
prenait un repas on va expliquer leur
part on mesure alors déchets et puis à
la prochaine fois que ce repas sera
proposé à niveau aux enfants on remet
mesurera le niveau de déchets produits
et on verra par cette paix des
pédagogies qui a été mis en place si on
arrivait la produire un peu moins de
déchets et des bénéfices de tout ce
qu'on essaie de faire s'ils ont pu tenir
je vous propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces
mots merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous l'avez
compris c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau temps d'échangé d'ici là bien
sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]